Someone who works with our radio show, Bianca Giaever, went to this presentation at Columbia University a while back where two people onstage puzzled over this thing they had found online called Wake Up Now. And I say "thing they found online," because the whole point of their presentation was it was hard to tell exactly what it was.
一位与我们广播节目合作的同事，比安卡·贾维尔（Bianca Giaever），前阵子在哥伦比亚大学参加了一场演讲，台上两个人对着他们在网上发现的一个叫“唤醒现在”（Wake Up Now）的东西感到困惑。我之所以说“在网上发现的东西”，是因为他们演讲的核心重点就是，很难说清那到底是什么。
Why do some people live their lives in black and white while others seem to live in vibrant color? Well, part of it is knowing a secret, a secret that changes how people see the world. This video is your invitation to WakeUpNow.
为什么有些人过着黑白色的生活，而另一些人似乎生活在绚丽的色彩中？嗯，部分原因在于了解一个秘密，一个改变人们看待世界方式的秘密。这段视频就是你加入“唤醒现在”的邀请函。
This is a video that was on WakeUpNow's website, which just looked like a kind of generic corporate-y website. And WakeUpNow seemed to be a company. But it was hard to tell exactly what the company did. This site talked about joining, about becoming a member, about living a better life. So was it a club? Was it an organization?
这是“唤醒现在”网站上的一段视频，看起来就像是一个普通的企业网站。“唤醒现在”似乎是一家公司，但很难说清这家公司到底是做什么的。网站上谈论着加入、成为会员，以及过上更好的生活。所以，这是一家俱乐部吗？是一个组织吗？
And then, when you googled WakeUpNow, there were tons of videos. Bianca saw some at the presentation at Columbia. And then, after the presentation, she started Googling on her own. And then, she sucked one of our producers, Brian Reed, into the vortex with her. Here is one of the videos they found.
然后，当你用谷歌搜索“唤醒现在”时，会出现海量的视频。比安卡在哥伦比亚大学的演讲中看到了一些。演讲结束后，她开始自己上网搜索。接着，她把我们的制作人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）也一起拉进了这个旋涡。这就是他们发现的视频之一。
Hey, we're here in Cancun with the greatest team in the world, WakeUpNow. You should have been here. All the leaders are here. We're having fun. Beautiful island.
嘿，我们现在在坎昆，和世界上最棒的团队“唤醒现在”在一起。你本该来的。所有的领导者都在这里。我们玩得很开心。美丽的岛屿。
This is a video of a bunch of young people hanging out on the beach. You can see jet skis and the ocean. In the video, they refer to this as a leadership summit. And there was a whole genre of videos just like this, people in exotic locations, riding around in nice looking cars or, in this one, spelunking in a cave in Mexico, chanting.
这是一段一群年轻人在海滩上闲逛的视频。你可以看到摩托艇和海洋。在视频中，他们称这为领导力峰会。像这样的视频类型有很多，人们出现在充满异国情调的地方，坐着看起来很高级的车，或者像这一段，在墨西哥的洞穴里探险，大声呼喊。
[MUSIC - "LA BAMBA"]
[音乐 - “拉班巴”]
That is, of course, WakeUpNow with "La Bamba." And then, there were a lot of videos with the word "scam" in the title, like "WakeUpNow is a scam, for real exposed truth." And so, these two producers on our staff were like, oh, so this is some kind of internet scam. But then, when they watched the videos, it seemed very different. Like, take this one for example titled, "WakeUpNow Warning, Don't Join Until You See This."
那当然是“唤醒现在”在唱《拉班巴》。此外，还有很多标题里带有“诈骗”字眼的视频，比如“‘唤醒现在’是骗局，揭露真实真相”。所以，我们制作组的这两位制作人当时心想，噢，原来这是某种互联网诈骗。但当他们观看视频时，情况似乎大不相同。比如，以这段视频为例，标题是“‘唤醒现在’警告，看这个之前不要加入”。
WakeUpNow is one of the most legitimate companies out there. The reason why is because--
“唤醒现在”是目前最合法的公司之一。原因在于——
So "WakeUpNow Warning, Don't Join Till You See This" is actually not a warning at all but entirely about how great WakeUpNow is. And in fact, there were so many videos like this, a video called "Five Reasons Not to Join WakeUpNow" offered not a single reason why not to join WakeUpNow, but instead went on to describe what a super awesome company it is.
所以这个“‘唤醒现在’警告，看这个之前不要加入”其实根本不是什么警告，而是完全在讲述“唤醒现在”有多棒。事实上，像这样的视频有很多，有一个视频叫“不要加入‘唤醒现在’的五个理由”，里面竟然没提供一个不加入的理由，反而继续描述这是一家多么超级棒的公司。
So I'm joined in the studio right now by the two producers who were watching all these videos, Brian and Bianca. Hi, guys.
现在和我一起在演播室里的，是观看了所有这些视频的两位制作人，布莱恩和比安卡。你们好。
Hi.
你好。
Hey.
嘿。
So at that point, as best as you could tell, what was WakeUpNow?
所以当时据你们所知，“唤醒现在”到底是什么？
We honestly didn't know. Like, we couldn't figure it out. We eventually put some research in. We learned that, later, this move, the scam thing--
我们真的不知道。我们研究不出来。我们后来做了一些调查。我们了解到，后来这种手段，就是诈骗那一套——
You mean labeling videos "Such and Such is a Scam"?
你是说把视频贴上“某某某是骗局”的标签？
Yeah, exactly that. And then, having it not actually talk about it being a scam. So that's a move, I guess, that some people who are involved with certain companies or selling certain products will do. Like, that's a thing, I guess. But I'd never seen a video like that before. And it was really confusing.
是的，正是那样。然后里面其实根本不提它是个骗局。我想，这大概是一些参与某些公司或销售某些产品的人会用的套路。这算是一种手段吧。但我以前从未见过这样的视频。这真的很让人困惑。
I mean, in so many of these WakeUpNow videos, we could tell people we're pitching something. But as far as we could tell, it wasn't a product.
我的意思是，在这么多“唤醒现在”的视频中，我们能看出人们在推销什么东西。但据我们所知，那并不是产品。
(SINGING) Build a bank, ah! I say, I say, I say, you need to build a bank, ah!
（歌唱）建立银行，啊！我说，我说，我说，你需要建立银行，啊！
So what is this?
所以这是什么？
This is a video of a guy who calls himself Panama. And it's titled "WakeUpNow Scam, Lend a Hand, Build a Man, Woman."
这是一个自称巴拿马（Panama）的家伙的视频。标题是“‘唤醒现在’骗局，伸出援手，成就男男女女”。
What are you doing? Eating carrots? Tomatoes? [SPEAKING SPANISH]
你在干什么？吃胡萝卜？西红柿？[西班牙语]
So yeah, it wasn't really clear what WakeUpNow was. But still, there were hundreds of these videos. It was like this whole subculture with all these people, about thousands of people.
所以说，真的不清楚“唤醒现在”到底是什么。但即便如此，还是有数百个这样的视频。这就像是一个整个亚文化，有成千上万的人。
OK, so then, I know what happened next is that you found out that WakeUpNow had a conference coming up, right?
好的，接下来的事情我知道了，你们发现“唤醒现在”要举办一场会议，对吧？
Yeah, and we went to try and figure out what this was.
是的，我们去那里是想弄明白这到底是什么。
Yeah, and what we eventually found out is that it's something called "network marketing." It's a network marketing company. But also what we found out is that that is a very bland term for something completely mind-blowing, way beyond anything we could have imagined.
没错，我们最终发现这是一种叫做“网络营销”的东西。这是一家网络营销公司。但我们也发现，对于某种完全让人震惊、超乎我们想象的事物来说，这是一个非常平淡的术语。
So today on our radio program, Wake Up Now. If nothing else, I have to say, that is a completely genius name for a company. It promises so much so efficiently. That you'll open your eyes. You're life will be totally different, totally better.
所以，今天我们的广播节目谈论“唤醒现在”。如果不说别的，我必须说，这作为公司名字真是太天才了。它极其高效地做出了如此多的承诺。让你睁开眼睛。你的生活将会完全不同，完全更好。
And so, today, as New Year's approaches, as lots of people take stock of who they've been and make resolutions about who they want to be, we have stories of people in very different contexts who try to wake up and wake up others. Stay with us.
所以，今天随着新年临近，当许多人回顾过去并为想成为什么样的人做出决定时，我们有一些故事，讲述人们在完全不同的背景下试图醒来并唤醒他人。请继续收听。
Act 1, Something's Happening Here and You Don't Know What It Is. So Brian and Bianca headed to WakeUpNow's conference in New York City at a hotel in Times Square to try to figure out what this was. Here they are, Brian and Bianca.
第一幕，这里发生了一些事，而你不知道是什么。所以布莱恩和比安卡前往位于纽约时代广场一家酒店举行的“唤醒现在”会议，试图弄清楚这到底是什么。他们就在现场，布莱恩和比安卡。
I'm a little embarrassed to admit this. But even after being at this conference for several hours, if you put a gun to my head and asked me what WakeUpNow is, what it does, I still don't think I could have told you.
我很尴尬地承认这一点。但即使在这个会议待了几个小时后，如果有人拿枪指着我的头问我“唤醒现在”是什么、它是做什么的，我仍然觉得我无法告诉你。
We talked to dozens of participants. And what we learned is that people were incredibly excited about something they weren't terribly good at explaining.
我们采访了数十名参与者。我们了解到的是，人们对他们无法准确解释的事情感到难以置信的兴奋。
Why do WakeUpNow? This is a new beginning for the new generation.
为什么要加入“唤醒现在”？这是新一代的全新开始。
What is it? I don't even know what it is.
它是什么？我甚至不知道它是什么。
Oh, it's a software company.
噢，它是一家软件公司。
It's a software company, you said?
你说它是一家软件公司？
I think.
我想是吧。
People had come from all over, East Coast, Minnesota, California. They're mostly young and mostly people of color. They called WakeUpNow a lifestyle. They talked about WUN life, W-U-N, for WakeUpNow.
人们从各地赶来，东海岸、明尼苏达州、加利福尼亚州。他们大多很年轻，大多是有色人种。他们把“唤醒现在”称为一种生活方式。他们谈论“WUN生活”，W-U-N，代表“唤醒现在”。
For the longest time, I couldn't even figure out what to call the hundreds of people at this conference. Were they customers of WakeUpNow? Employees? Card-carrying members? Whatever they were, some of them could list specific WakeUpNow products.
很长一段时间里，我甚至不知道该如何称呼这次会议上的数百人。他们是“唤醒现在”的客户吗？员工？持证会员？无论他们是什么，其中一些人能列出具体的“唤醒现在”产品。
And the product is?
产品是什么？
Awaken Thunder.
Awaken Thunder（觉醒雷霆）。
What's Wake and Thunder?
什么是Awaken Thunder？
Awaken Thunder. It's--
Awaken Thunder。它是——
What is that?
那是什么？
--an energy drink. An energy drink.
——一种能量饮料。一种能量饮料。
Oh, so you're selling an energy drink.
噢，所以你们在卖能量饮料。
We're not selling it. You can buy it.
我们不是在卖它。你可以买它。
OK. I'm just try-- so are you guys going to work for the company? Or you're buying the product?
好的。我只是想——所以你们是要去这家公司工作吗？还是你们在买产品？
Well, we don't have to buy the product. So what you do is you just go around and spread the word about it.
嗯，我们不必买产品。所以你要做的就是四处宣传它。
But are you selling an energy drink, though? I'm confused.
但你们是在卖能量饮料吗？我困惑了。
No, we don't have to sell it.
不，我们不必卖它。
The company offers it.
公司提供它。
Yeah.
是的。
The company offers it for you. It's exclusive only for the people that are in WakeUpNow.
公司为你提供。它只对那些加入“唤醒现在”的人独家供应。
So there are products. And these people encouraged other people to buy them. But when we tried to use the word "selling," we were corrected.
所以有产品。这些人鼓励其他人购买它们。但当我们试图使用“销售”这个词时，我们被纠正了。
Yeah, I mean, I don't like saying "selling." I like using "providing." I provide people with it.
是的，我的意思是，我不喜欢说“销售”。我喜欢用“提供”。我向人们提供它。
Do they pay you money in exchange?
他们会付钱给你作为交换吗？
No, not really. I got a commission from it. That's  about it.
不，并不是真的。我从中得到佣金。就这些。
Awaken Thunder energy drink was not the only thing WakeUpNow was not selling, but providing. People seemed to be listing a totally random assortment of products.
Awaken Thunder能量饮料并不是“唤醒现在”唯一没有在销售、而是在“提供”的东西。人们似乎在列出一堆完全随机的产品。
Lots of things people said WakeUpNow offered were just discounts, off their AT&T phone bills, purchases at Office Depot, on groceries.
人们说“唤醒现在”提供的许多东西只是折扣，AT&T电话费折扣、Office Depot购物折扣、杂货折扣。
We have the Trivanis.
我们有Trivanis。
What are those?
那些是什么？
They're like lotion, skin products.
它们就像乳液、护肤品。
And then, we have the coffee.
然后，我们有咖啡。
We have cyber-protection.
我们有网络安全保护。
Have you ever wanted to learn another language? well we have a program that has 80 languages, similar to Rosetta Stone.
你曾经想学习另一种语言吗？好吧，我们有一个拥有80种语言的程序，类似于罗塞塔石碑（Rosetta Stone）。
There's a vacation club.
有一个度假俱乐部。
For example, I'm going to Florida. Hotel's usually $1,100. I'm going to pay $290 for the whole week, a condo.
例如，我要去佛罗里达。酒店通常要1100美元。我整个星期只要支付290美元，住公寓。
There's tax software.
有税务软件。
Most people can increase their tax deduction by $3,000 to $6,000 per year, just by the tax part alone.
大多数人每年可以增加3000到6000美元的税收抵扣，仅通过税务部分就能实现。
But in this sea of hard-to-understand information and unrelated products, one thing everyone seemed to agree on, WakeUpNow had a mission.
但在这一片难以理解的信息和不相关的产品海洋中，有一点似乎每个人都同意：这就是“唤醒现在”有一个使命。
WakeUpNow actually is a financial wellness company, showing people how to save, manage, and make money.
“唤醒现在”实际上是一家财务健康公司，向人们展示如何储蓄、管理和赚钱。
In fact, so many people recited this mission so precisely, it was actually a bit weird.
事实上，有那么多人如此精确地背诵这个使命，这确实有点怪异。
We'll save money, manage money, and make money.
我们将省钱、管理金钱和赚钱。
Save money, make money, and manage your money.
省钱、赚钱和管理你的钱。
Save, manage, and make money.
省钱、管理和赚钱。
Save money, manage money, and make more money.
省钱、管理金钱，并赚更多的钱。
Save, manage, and make money at the same time.
同时省钱、管理和赚钱。
It took us all day and, honestly, quite a bit more research afterwards, including signing up ourselves-- which was really complicated-- to piece together how WakeUpNow works. Like I said earlier, they're a network marketing company. And if you haven't heard that term, you've probably heard of Amway or Herbalife or New-Skin, companies where you sell things to people you know. That's network marketing.
我们花了一整天，老实说，之后还做了不少研究，包括我们自己注册——这真的非常复杂——才拼凑出“唤醒现在”是如何运作的。就像我之前说的，他们是一家网络营销公司。如果你没听说过这个术语，你可能听说过安利（Amway）、康宝莱（Herbalife）或如新（New-Skin），这些公司就是向你认识的人兜售东西。这就是网络营销。
When you join WakeUpNow, you get access to a place on their website called The Hub, which is where you can purchase many of the products and services we heard about. You can join for free. But you're encouraged to sign up on a plan where you pay between $80 and $150 a month. You pay more money, you get more stuff, like the financial management and tax software.
当你加入“唤醒现在”，你就可以进入他们网站上一个叫“枢纽”（The Hub）的地方，在那里你可以购买我们听到的许多产品和服务。你可以免费加入。但我们鼓励你注册一个每月支付80到150美元的计划。你付的钱越多，得到的东西就越多，比如财务管理和税务软件。
So that's the saving money and managing money part of WakeUpNow. As for the making money part, you can make money by recruiting other people to join WakeUpNow. They buy stuff, you can earn commission. They recruit people, you make money off that too. A chain forms below you.
所以这就是“唤醒现在”的省钱和管理金钱部分。至于赚钱部分，你可以通过招募其他人加入“唤醒现在”来赚钱。他们购买东西，你可以赚取佣金。他们招募其他人，你也能从中赚钱。你下方形成了一条链条。
That's the network in network marketing. You get three people to join, you get $100. If each of them gets three people to join, that's when the real money kicks in, about $600 a month. There are other ways to earn that money. But that's the one we saw them push.
这就是网络营销中的“网络”。你让三个人加入，你得到100美元。如果他们每个人都让三个人加入，那就是真正的钱开始涌入的时候，大约每月600美元。还有其他赚钱方式。但这是我们看到他们推崇的一种。
I know, this may sound like a pyramid scheme. Whether it is one, though, would have to be decided by the courts. We called the Federal Trade Commission. And a spokesman said figuring out if a network marketing company is a pyramid scheme is very difficult and takes a long investigation. The FTC's website says a good tip off that a network marketing company might be a pyramid scheme is that members earn more money for recruiting new members than for selling products to the public.
我知道，这听起来可能像传销。不过它是否是传销，必须由法院决定。我们给联邦贸易委员会（FTC）打了电话。一位发言人表示，判断一家网络营销公司是否为传销非常困难，需要长时间的调查。FTC的网站说，一家网络营销公司可能是传销的一个很好的迹象是，成员因招募新成员赚的钱比向公众销售产品赚的钱更多。
WakeUpNow's chief marketing officer told us that 100% of the company's profits come from product sales. But when you pay a monthly fee to join, they consider that a product. He said WakeUpNow is absolutely not a pyramid scheme.
“唤醒现在”的首席营销官告诉我们，公司100%的利润来自产品销售。但当你支付月费加入时，他们将其视为产品。他说“唤醒现在”绝对不是传销。
For now though, WakeUpNow members are charging forth, recruiting more and more people into the company and, apparently, getting paid a boatload to do it.
不过目前，“唤醒现在”的成员正在奋力前进，招募越来越多的人进入公司，并且显然，为此赚取了巨额财富。
Boom, boom, boom. Just watch, probably 500K a month walked by you.
轰，轰，轰。看好了，走过你身边的可能就是月入50万的人。
This guy's pointing at a group of otherwise ordinary looking people. He's talking about all their salaries added together.
这个家伙指着一群看起来很普通的人。他说的是他们所有人的薪水总和。
500K a month?
月入50万？
500K a month just walked by you, under 25-years-old.
月入50万刚从你身边走过，25岁以下。
This company is making history actually. This company is creating the largest amount of under 30-year-old 6-figure-earner that I've ever seen. Look, 6-figure-earner, 6-figure-earner.
这家公司实际上正在创造历史。这家公司正在创造我所见过的最多数量的30岁以下6位数收入者。看，6位数收入者，6位数收入者。
People loved pointing out all the 6-figure-earner magnates among us. In our first few minutes of the conference, I saw this big bearded man. Someone else called him, quote, "a freaking duck hunter guy," which seemed like an apt description. People lined up to take pictures with him. Someone nearby told me why.
人们喜欢指出我们中间所有的6位数收入大亨。在会议的前几分钟，我看到了这个大胡子男人。有人称他为“那个该死的养鸭人”，这似乎是一个恰当的描述。人们排队和他合影。附近有人告诉我原因。
My boy right here is making $114,000 a month right now, $114,000.
我这位兄弟现在月收入11.4万美元，11.4万。
$114,000?
11.4万？
$114,000 a month.
一个月11.4万。
His name? See More Green. That's S-E-E M-O-R-E Green. See More is the top earner in WakeUpNow. He's been doing it a year. He's 25. Everybody knew who he was and how much he allegedly made. Later in the day, WakeUpNow gave See More Green an award for being number one.
他的名字？See More Green（意为：赚更多钱）。拼写是S-E-E M-O-R-E Green。See More是“唤醒现在”收入最高的人。他做了一年了。他25岁。每个人都知道他是谁，以及他据称赚了多少钱。当天晚些时候，“唤醒现在”给See More Green颁发了一个奖项，因为他是第一名。
(CHANTING) See More!
（呼喊）See More！
See More Green!
See More Green！
See More! See More! See More! See More! See More! See More!
See More！See More！See More！See More！See More！See More！
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Wow!
哇！
A woman near me says, he's a regular dude. He's wearing a t-shirt. You would never know.
我身边的一位女士说，他是个普通人。他穿着T恤。你永远看不出来。
You would never know.
你永远看不出来。
You'd never know, right?
你永远看不出来，对吧？
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
Another thing we encountered at the conference was a repulsion to something so unsavory, so unseemly, that WakeUpNow's emcee for the day couldn't even bear to speak the word aloud. So he spelled it out instead.
我们在会议上遇到的另一件事是对某种令人不快、如此不得体的事情的排斥，以至于“唤醒现在”当天的司仪甚至无法忍受大声说出这个词。所以他把它拼了出来。
There are so many people in a J-O-B that are bored. There's no reason they just another one of them.
有太多人在做一份J-O-B（工作），感到厌烦。没有理由他们只是其中之一。
J-O-B. Quick warning, I'm going to say the word right now, job.
J-O-B。小提醒，我现在要说这个词了，工作（job）。
When you go into a store and you run into an employee with a J-O-B, and you can see it in their face. There is no energy, because they're not invested in what they're doing. It's not their business. I'm looking at a room full of people who care, because it's their business. It is their future. That is why I love this industry.
当你走进一家商店遇到一个有J-O-B的员工，你可以从他们的脸上看出来。没有任何活力，因为他们没有投入到他们正在做的事情中。这不是他们的生意。我看到的是一屋子关心的人，因为这是他们的生意。这是他们的未来。这就是我热爱这个行业的原因。
This dissatisfaction with 9-to-5s ran deep through the crowd. Take this paralegal. How does she describe her job?
这种对“朝九晚五”的不满在人群中根深蒂固。看看这个法律助理。她怎么描述她的工作？
It's a soul-sucking, like, life-destroying, "sit at a desk all day and get fat" waste of life.
那是一份灵魂被吞噬、像是毁灭生活、“整天坐在桌子旁发胖”的人生浪费。
She told me that as soon as her income from WakeUpNow inches above her current salary, she's outta there.
她告诉我，只要她从“唤醒现在”获得的收入稍微超过她目前的工资，她就会离开那里。
It could be, like, $1 more than I'm making now. I'm quitting. Like, literally, $1. OK, I quit. I'm not coming in ever.
哪怕只比我现在赚的多1美元。我就辞职。真的，1美元。好吧，我不干了。我再也不来了。
Of course, lots of jobs do suck. A surprising number of attendees at the conference told us they were planning on quitting to pursue WakeUpNow. These appear to be people with steady full-time E-M-P-L-O-Y-M-E-N-T, a compliance manager at a big bank, a human resources person at Coca-Cola.
当然，很多工作确实很烂。在会议上，令人惊讶数量的参加者告诉我们，他们正计划辞职去追求“唤醒现在”。这些人似乎都有稳定的全职E-M-P-L-O-Y-M-E-N-T（就业），一家大银行的合规经理，可口可乐的人力资源人员。
And we also met people who had actually done it. One person quit a restaurant. Another quit his sales job at Samsung. Plus, there was this guy.
我们也遇到了真正做到这一点的人。一个人辞掉了餐馆的工作。另一个人辞掉了他在三星的销售工作。此外，还有这个人。
Antonio "Unemployable" Johnson.
安东尼奥“无法雇佣的”约翰逊（Antonio "Unemployable" Johnson）。
He quit his job two years ago. Now, he has a motto.
他两年前辞职了。现在，他有一句座右铭。
Friends don't let friends get jobs.
朋友不让朋友去找工作。
It's clear why lots of people would want to leave their current lousy jobs. What's not so clear is why they'd choose to leave them for WakeUpNow. When you look at the WakeUpNow compensation plan, which we did later, it actually says in there how many members are making a small profit, 4%. That's it.
很明显，为什么很多人想离开他们目前糟糕的工作。不太清楚的是，为什么他们会选择为“唤醒现在”离开。当你查看“唤醒现在”的薪酬计划时，我们后来做了，里面实际上说了有多少成员在赚取小额利润，4%。就这些。
And those 4% are not making a living, just an average of about $600 a month. The number of people making anything close to resembling a living is about 1%. Those are the company's numbers. If they're accurate, presumably 95% of the people chanting in this conference room weren't making any profit whatsoever.
而且这4%的人并没有以此为生，平均每月只有600美元左右。接近以此为生的人数大约是1%。这是公司的数据。如果它们准确的话，大概会议室里呼喊的95%的人根本没有赚到任何利润。
(CHANTING) WakeUpNow! WakeUpNow! WakeUpNow! WakeUpNow! WakeUpNow! WakeUpNow! WakeUpNow!
（呼喊）唤醒现在！唤醒现在！唤醒现在！唤醒现在！唤醒现在！唤醒现在！唤醒现在！
This is the beginning of the main event, what was billed as a business presentation that stretched on for nearly five hours with more than a dozen speakers. A lot of it was about how to recruit people into WakeUpNow.
这是主活动的开始，被称为商业演示，持续了近五个小时，有十几位演讲者。其中很多内容是关于如何招募人们进入“唤醒现在”。
I should say, officially, the company doesn't use the word "recruit." But there's no other way to describe what we saw. It was about recruiting. Like this advice from a guy named Rob McFadden. He said that, on the day you launch your WakeUpNow business--
我应该正式说明，公司不使用“招募”这个词。但没有其他词可以描述我们所看到的。这确实是在招募。比如这个叫罗布·麦克法登（Rob McFadden）的人的建议。他说，在你启动“唤醒现在”业务的那天——
You set up a conference call at 10:00 AM. You invite everybody you know to be on that call. On that call, all you tell them is, I'm launching. We're going nuts. I can't even tell you what we're doing. I have a call scheduled at noon. Who's going to be on it?
你安排一个上午10点的电话会议。你邀请你认识的所有人参加那个电话。在那个电话里，你只需要告诉他们，我要启动了。我们要疯狂起来了。我甚至不能告诉你我们在做什么。我定了一个中午的电话。谁会参加？
The next step was to get each person on the 10:00 AM call to bring 10 more people with them to the noon call and, then, to do the exact same thing over again for a 2 o'clock call, all with no mention of what the business actually is. After all--
下一步是让上午10点电话会议上的每个人再带10个人参加中午的电话会议，然后，为下午2点的电话会议做完全相同的事情，全程不提这个生意到底是什么。毕竟——
People care more about how you say something that anything you ever say.
人们关心你说话的方式，胜过你所说的任何话。
The fact that they called this event a business presentation was strange, because there was so little actual business discussed. So much of it was just motivational speeches.
他们称这次活动为商业演示的事实很奇怪，因为讨论的实际业务很少。其中大部分只是励志演讲。
And you being here today, I got to give you props. Because you get it. You get it. You're changing lives. You're starting a movement.
你今天能在这里，我得给你点赞。因为你懂。你懂。你正在改变生活。你正在发起一场运动。
You don't got a dream, you don't have a roadmap. You don't have a roadmap, you ain't taking a trip.
你没有梦想，就没有路线图。你没有路线图，你就没在旅行。
See, what is it that drives you? Is it feeding starving kids? Is it making a difference in this world?
看，是什么驱动着你？是喂饱饥饿的孩子吗？是在这个世界上有所作为吗？
I saw a vision to help people. I saw a vision to change the world. You have the ability to speak life or death into people. WakeUpNow is  speaking life.
我看到了帮助人们的愿景。我看到了改变世界的愿景。你有能力向人们传达生命或死亡。“唤醒现在”正在传达生命。
This was the aspect of the conference that we really struggled to make sense of, the contrast between this vision of WakeUpNow changing the world, speaking life into people, and the reality of what it seemed like WakeUpNow is actually doing, which is selling energy drinks and giving people discounts on random stuff.
这是会议中我们真正努力去理解的方面，即“唤醒现在”改变世界、向人们传达生命的愿景，与“唤醒现在”实际似乎在做的事情（即销售能量饮料并给人们提供随机东西的折扣）之间的反差。
Now, product announcements, guys. It wouldn't be--
现在，产品发布，各位。如果不是——
This crystallized during the single most confusing moment of the conference, the big announcement they made in between inspirational speeches. The company's marketing director, Jordan Harris, took the stage.
这在会议中最令人困惑的时刻结晶了，他们在励志演讲之间做出的重大宣布。公司的营销总监乔丹·哈里斯（Jordan Harris）走上舞台。
Nobody else outside this room knows anything about what we're about to talk about.
除了这个房间里的人，没有人知道我们要谈论什么。
And what he went on to talk about was coupons. WakeUpNow members have access to coupons that they can print out and use to get money off at local businesses.
他继续谈论的是优惠券。 “唤醒现在”成员可以访问优惠券，他们可以打印出来，用于在当地企业消费时抵扣钱。
How many of you guys have smartphones? OK, pull out your smartphones real quick. How cool would it be if, instead of having to print the  coupon, you just showed your smartphone.
你们当中有多少人有智能手机？好的，快速拿出你们的智能手机。如果不需要打印优惠券，而是直接展示你的智能手机，那该多酷啊。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
Right? This is awesome. So guys, we're excited. Today, we're announcing our new iPhone and Android app that's going to let you do just that.
对吧？这太棒了。所以各位，我们很兴奋。今天，我们要宣布我们新的iPhone和安卓应用，它将让你做到这一点。
[LOUD CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[大声欢呼和掌声]
The big announcement was that you no longer had to print the coupons out. You could now just use a smartphone app.
重大宣布是，你不再需要打印优惠券。你现在只需使用智能手机应用程序。
Let's talk about when it's going to launch. OK, it's going to be available-- two weeks.
让我们谈谈它什么时候推出。好的，它将在两周内可用。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
What do you think? I think we can do better. Let's just do it today.
你们觉得呢？我觉得我们可以做得更好。今天就做吧。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
That's right. You can go in the iPhone store and Android store and download this today!
没错。你们今天就可以去iPhone商店和安卓商店下载这个！
After this, Brian and I had to check with each other. We honestly weren't sure if we had missed something. This excitement was over coupons?
在此之后，布莱恩和我不得不互相核对。我们真的不确定是否错过了什么。这种兴奋是因为优惠券？
The emcee couldn't even move on with the presentation after this, because everyone was so overwhelmed.
司仪在此之后甚至无法继续演讲，因为每个人都太不知所措了。
Wow, that is-- I'm-- I'm beside myself. I know, you're all looking. It's OK, take your time. Wow. All right, we're all catching our breath. It's OK. Yeah, day might as well be over for some of you.
哇，那是——我——我难以自持。我知道，你们都在看。没关系，慢慢来。哇。好了，我们都在喘口气。没关系。是的，对你们中的一些人来说，这一天大概也就这样了。
We left the conference not sure what to think of what we'd witnessed. But the fact that people were talking about quitting their jobs to do WakeUpNow, when the chances of making any kind of living were so low, that seemed alarming.
离开会议时，我们不知道该如何看待我们所目睹的一切。但人们谈论辞掉工作去做“唤醒现在”，而过上任何体面生活的机会却如此渺茫，这看起来令人担忧。
And to our surprise, when we interviewed WakeUpNow's Chief Marketing Officer Jordan Harris, the guy who made the coupon announcement, he said that isn't meant to be the company's message. They don't want everyone quitting their jobs.
令我们惊讶的是，当我们采访“唤醒现在”的首席营销官乔丹·哈里斯（即宣布优惠券的那个人）时，他说这并不是公司的初衷。他们不希望每个人都辞掉工作。
There's an element of any live event, like we have, where sometimes people get up there and they get excited. And there's things that you'd rather have them not say. Our standard advice for people, you should be replacing your income for at least three to four months consistently through WakeUpNow before you consider it.
任何现场活动都有一个因素，像我们有的一样，有时人们会站在上面，他们会很兴奋。有些事情你宁愿他们别说。我们给人们的标准建议是，在考虑辞职之前，你应该通过“唤醒现在”持续至少三到四个月来替代你的收入。
So on WakeUpNow's Income Disclosure Statement, it says that 4% of members make a profit. Do you think most people who are doing WakeUpNow as a business know that number?
那么在“唤醒现在”的收入披露声明上，写着4%的成员获得了利润。你认为大多数做“唤醒现在”作为生意的人知道那个数字吗？
I think, no question. That is so widely disseminated. You can go pull income disclosure statements from--
我想，毫无疑问。那被广泛传播。你可以去获取收入披露声明——
You guys-- like, I don't think you mentioned it aloud at the conference.
你们——就像，我不认为你们在会议上大声提到过。
Yeah, we don't mention it aloud. But it's like, it is--
是的，我们没有大声提到它。但就像，它是——
Why not?
为什么不呢？
--on our website, on every-- eh? In a conference, when you're out there talking to them, it didn't come up. We're at a conference. We're trying to have high energy. We're there to have a lot of fun. That's not something that is pitched from stage. But we make sure that everybody is aware of it. I don't know if you saw to stage left. There was an income disclosure statement on the wall. It was in the booklet that everybody got.
——在我们的网站上，在每一处——呃？在会议中，当你在外面和他们交谈时，它没提起来。我们在会议中。我们试图保持高能量。我们在那里是为了玩得很开心。那不是台上推销的东西。但我们确保每个人都知道它。我不知道你是否看到舞台左侧。墙上有一份收入披露声明。在每个人拿到的小册子里也有。
So everybody left with that income disclosure statement in their hand. We don't want people joining with the idea that, hey, you promised me, if I joined, I would make this amount. That's not what we care about. We care about changing your financial situation from the products. And if you'd like to supplement it by making money, you have an opportunity.
所以每个人离开时手里都拿着那份收入披露声明。我们不希望人们带着这种想法加入，嘿，你向我承诺，如果我加入，我会赚这么多钱。那不是我们在意的。我们在意的是通过产品改变你的财务状况。如果你想通过赚钱来补充它，你有一个机会。
We told Jordan this wasn't the measured message we left the conference with. Instead, in a room where less than 1% was making any real money from WakeUpNow, we heard speakers spinning a fantasy of enormous wealth, infinity pools, trips to Cancun. One speaker had the crowd shout out their favorite fancy cars, Maseratis and Porsches.
我们告诉乔丹，这不是我们离开会议时得到的衡量过的信息。相反，在一个不到1%的人从“唤醒现在”赚到任何真正金钱的房间里，我们听到演讲者在编造财富的幻想，无边泳池，去坎昆的旅行。一位演讲者让群众大声喊出他们最喜欢的豪车，玛莎拉蒂和保时捷。
Jordan understood why we got this impression. But he says that's not WakeUpNow is really about. He says their company was built around the idea of helping people make an extra $500 or $600 a month and that they chose that number deliberately.
乔丹明白为什么我们会有这种印象。但他说是那不是“唤醒现在”真正关于的内容。他说他们的公司建立在帮助人们每月额外赚取500或600美元的想法上，他们是故意选择这个数字的。
Because we look at the statistics and the majority of bankruptcies could avoid it if they had $500 more per month. And so, really, if we can get a ton of people that are earning $500 to $600 a month, then for us, that's our sweet spot. We're not encouraging people to just walk away from their own personal income. We're just trying to be something in the middle that helps it be easier every single month.
因为我们查看统计数据，如果多数破产的人每月多有500美元，他们本可以避免破产。所以真的，如果我们能让大量的人每月赚500到600美元，那么对我们来说，这就是我们的甜点。我们不是在鼓励人们直接放弃他们个人的收入。我们只是试图成为中间的东西，帮助每个月变得更容易。
Right, but from being at the conference, it just does seem like the messages are not that. They're not, we want to help you live a easier life every month with supplemental income and financial management.
对，但从在会议上来看，信息似乎并非如此。它们不是，我们想通过补充收入和财务管理帮助你每个月过上更容易的生活。
The message is much more like, your life is unsatisfactory. You are slave to some job. You don't have your own freedom. And this is the answer to that. The reality of the message I think people are getting is not what you just said. And does that concern you?
信息更像是，你的生活是不令人满意的。你是某份工作的奴隶。你没有自己的自由。而这是对那个问题的答案。我认为人们得到的信息现实并非你刚才所说的。这让你担心吗？
Yeah. We want to unify the message from corporate. Like I said, I think you guys caught us right in the spike of our growth where there were so many people that were involved in WakeUpNow that we didn't necessarily have as good as communication from corporate as we could have. But we're a different company than we were eight months ago.
是的。我们想统一来自公司的信息。就像我说的，我认为你们抓住了我们增长的尖峰，当时有太多人参与“唤醒现在”，以至于我们未必有来自公司尽可能好的沟通。但我们是一家与八个月前不同的公司。
The conference we went to was in April. Jordan says the company had grown 4,000% over the previous year. And they were scrambling to deal with that expansion. WakeUpNow, by the way, was only founded in 2009.
我们参加的会议是在四月。乔丹说公司在过去一年里增长了4000%。他们正忙于处理这种扩张。顺便说一下，“唤醒现在”成立于2009年。
Since April, Jordan says they're running a tighter ship. They recently replaced their CEO. They're rewriting some of their introductory literature, downplaying the recruiting side of things. And they've changed what they say at their events. He says, WakeUpNow has never been intentionally vague. But he thinks we were not unique in our confusion. And that's one of the things they're trying to fix.
自四月以来，乔丹说他们运营得更紧凑了。他们最近更换了首席执行官。他们正在重写一些介绍性资料，淡化招募方面的内容。而且他们改变了在活动中所说的内容。“唤醒现在”从未有意模糊，但他认为我们在困惑中并不独特。这也是他们试图解决的问题之一。
A couple weeks ago, we talked to a guy who studies companies like WakeUpNow, Amway and Herbalife and other network marketing companies. And he said, when reporters talk about them, they usually focus on the money people spend on them, but rarely discuss the part he considers more troubling and more destructive-- what it does to members' personal relationships.
几周前，我们和一位研究像“唤醒现在”、安利和康宝莱等网络营销公司的研究人员交谈。他说，当记者谈论他们时，通常关注的是人们在他们身上花费的金钱，但很少讨论他认为更令人担忧和更具破坏性的部分——它对成员人际关系的影响。
This guy's name is Robert L. Fitzpatrick. And he used a word to describe WakeUpNow that may sound hyperbolic. The word was "cult," except not a religious cult.
这个人叫罗伯特·L·菲茨帕特里克（Robert L. Fitzpatrick）。他用了一个词来描述“唤醒现在”，这听起来可能有些夸张。这个词是“邪教”（cult），只不过不是宗教邪教。
It's an economic cult. That's the distinction that I think you may be grasping for when you say, what is this thing?
这是一个经济邪教。这是我想当你说“这是什么东西”时，你可能想抓到的区别。
Robert Fitzpatrick says it's not an accident that it took us so long to figure out what WakeUpNow is, that the videos all seem so vague and the website was so confusing about pricing and products when we signed up as a member. He says, vagueness is part of a strategy companies use. Robert became interested in network marketing after he and some friends got caught up years ago in the frenzy of recruiting people into a gifting scheme.
罗伯特·菲茨帕特里克说，我们花了这么长时间才弄明白“唤醒现在”是什么并非偶然，那些视频看起来都如此模糊，当我们注册成为会员时，网站在定价和产品上如此令人困惑。他说，模糊性是公司使用策略的一部分。罗伯特在多年前他和一些朋友陷入招募人们进入赠礼计划的狂热后，对网络营销产生了兴趣。
And he says the most disturbing thing about it was how it manipulated their thinking, made them suspend critical judgment. So he spent years researching how network marketing companies work. A regular business, Robert says, doesn't try to tell people how to treat their friends and family, which we saw at WakeUpNow.
他说其中最令人不安的是它如何操纵他们的思维，让他们搁置批判性判断。所以他花了几年时间研究网络营销公司是如何运作的。罗伯特说，一家正规公司不会试图告诉人们如何对待他们的朋友和家人，而我们在“唤醒现在”看到了这一点。
The intention to isolate you from other people who are not in the scheme-- you are told to shun doubters, critics, even if they're in your family.
意图是将你与计划外的人隔离开来——你被告知要避开怀疑者、批评者，即使他们是你的家人。
And then, when you go around your friends and  they get uncomfortable, like, you buggin'! Guess what? You know who to walk away from.
然后，当你去拜访朋友，他们感到不舒服时，比如，你真是个麻烦！猜怎么着？你知道该避开谁了。
[AFFIRMATIONS]
[肯定语]
You know who to walk away from, because they can't understand your language. They won't be able to understand your language.
你知道该避开谁，因为他们听不懂你的语言。他们无法理解你的语言。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
Dream big. Dream big.
梦想远大。梦想远大。
So isolation-- and the other is a certain requirement of blind faith and obedience. You're not supposed to question. Critical thinking is for losers. You will see it when you believe it.
所以隔离——另一个是盲目信仰和服从的某种要求。你不应该质疑。批判性思维是给失败者准备的。你相信了，你就会看到它。
This industry-- wrong. This busi-- no. This profession-- this profession rewards one thing. It rewards belief. How many of you believe you are Global sitting in that  chair right now?
这个行业——错。这个生意——不。这个职业——这个职业奖励一件事。它奖励信仰。现在坐在那张椅子上，你们有多少人相信你们是全球性的？
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
[MIC DROPPING]
[丢掉麦克风]
Global is the highest earning level in the company, the level See More Green is. That guy literally just dropped the mic, by the way.
全球性是公司最高的收入级别，See More Green所在的级别。顺便说一下，那个家伙刚才真的扔掉了麦克风。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
We asked WakeUpNow's Chief Marketing Officer Jordan Harris if the company is a cult. And no surprise here. He says that's an unfair characterization. He says, he interprets those moments from the conference differently than Robert Fitzpatrick does.
我们问“唤醒现在”的首席营销官乔丹·哈里斯公司是否是一个邪教。这并不意外。他说这是一个不公平的定性。他说，他对比罗伯特·菲茨帕特里克对会议中那些时刻的解读不同。
WakeUpNow is not trying to isolate members from their family, he says. But if someone's being negative about your work, he thinks it is good advice not to hang around them. And what's wrong with believing in what you do?
他说，“唤醒现在”并不是试图将成员与家人隔离开来。但如果有人对你的工作持负面态度，他认为不和他们交往是好建议。相信你所做的事情有什么错呢？
Look, if you're going to do anything, you better believe that you can do before you start. I think that that is a universal truth. But to portray it as, the only way to be successful is to believe hard enough-- I would much rather have them preface that with, it is not enough to succeed. You've got to have the hard work. And you've got to have the talent to be successful.
听着，如果你要做任何事情，你最好在开始之前就相信你能做到。我认为那是一个普遍真理。但如果将其描绘成，成功的唯一途径就是足够努力地去相信——我宁愿他们在此之前加上，光有信仰是不够成功的。你必须有努力工作。而且你必须有才能才能成功。
At the conference, everyone was so amped up. It was hard to get a sense of what it was really like to do WakeUpNow day in and day out. So we found someone who'd gone all in on WakeUpNow, who'd quit his job to dedicate himself to it, a guy with a wife and three young kids who recently stopped working in the kitchen of a really nice restaurant to do WakeUpNow.
在会议上，每个人都非常亢奋。很难感知到日复一日做“唤醒现在”是什么感觉。所以我们找到了一个全身心投入“唤醒现在”、辞掉工作全身心投入其中的人，一个有妻子和三个小孩的男人，他最近停止在一家非常好的餐馆厨房工作来做“唤醒现在”。
His name is Damien Lacks. He's 29 years old. We went to visit him at his apartment in Gettysburg, Pennsylvania. Damien grew up in a rough part of Baltimore. He was a charismatic kid, a good athlete who did well in school. But he got into drugs, dropped out, did some time in jail. By the time he was 24, he was living in a halfway house in Gettysburg, where he moved to get away from the city, and working at a McDonald's.
他叫达米恩·莱克斯（Damien Lacks）。他29岁。我们去宾夕法尼亚州葛底斯堡的公寓拜访了他。达米恩在巴尔的摩一个艰难的地方长大。他是一个有魅力的孩子，一个成绩优异的好运动员。但他开始吸毒，辍学，坐过牢。到24岁时，他住在葛底斯堡的一个中途宿舍里，为了远离城市而搬到那里，并在麦当劳工作。
I didn't know what I wanted to do with life. At the same time though-- and this might sound strange to some people-- even back then, even since I was 10 years old, I've known that I was supposed to do something great. Now, I ain't saying it to boast. I just am giving praise to God. Because that's who he made me. I haven't always lived up to it. I've been terrible at living up to it.
我不知道我一生中想做什么。但与此同时——这对某些人来说可能听起来很奇怪——即使在当时，甚至从我10岁起，我就知道我本应该做一些伟大的事情。现在，我不是在吹嘘。我只是在赞美上帝。因为那是他创造我的样子。我不总是能做到。我在实现它方面一直很糟糕。
After McDonald's, Damien worked in kitchens at a couple of pubs in town, then landed at a TGI Fridays. But Damien was bored there.
在麦当劳之后，达米恩在镇上的几家酒吧厨房工作，然后落脚于TGI Fridays。但达米恩在那里很无聊。
The district manager would walk in. He wouldn't speak to the little guys on the line. I hated that feeling, feeling like I'm a little guy. And that the big guys, who are already making $100,000 a year, when you come around, you don't even have the decency to say, hey, how are you guys doing in here?
区域经理会走进来。他不会和流水线上的小人物说话。我讨厌那种感觉，感觉自己是个小人物。而那些已经年入10万美元的大人物，当你出现时，甚至没有礼貌说，嘿，你们在这里做得怎么样？
You know, we hot. We sweating. We busting our ass. Excuse me. You don't really care about nothing but how the restaurant is running and how much money we're making. You don't care about the people at all. It makes you feel low. No, I hated that. I hated it.
你知道，我们很热。我们在流汗。我们拼命工作。对不起。你真的不在乎除了餐厅怎么运营以及我们赚了多少钱之外的任何事情。你根本不关心人。这让你感觉很卑微。不，我讨厌那样。我讨厌它。
In other words, it was a J-O-B. So he applied to one of the best restaurants in the area, a place called Restaurant Sydney, founded by a chef he admired. Damien was taking online culinary classes. He had dreams of becoming a sous chef, of one day opening his own restaurant. So when Sidney hired him, he was thrilled.
换句话说，这是一份J-O-B。所以他申请了该地区最好的餐馆之一，一家叫Restaurant Sydney的地方，由一位他敬佩的厨师创立。达米恩正在参加在线烹饪课程。他梦想成为一名副主厨，有朝一日开设自己的餐厅。所以当悉尼雇佣他时，他很激动。
What were your expectations going in there?
你进去时的期望是什么？
The highest level of chefness-- I don't know a better word. [LAUGH] And it wasn't all the way like that.
最高水平的厨师境界——我不知道更好的词。[笑] 情况并没有完全那样。
When it came down to it, working in the kitchen at Restaurant Sidney was still just working in a kitchen. His co-workers grumbled, told offensive jokes to pass the time. They didn't seem inspired.
当事情归结为，在Restaurant Sidney的厨房工作仍然只是在厨房工作。他的同事们抱怨，讲冒犯的笑话来打发时间。他们看起来并不受启发。
And Damien was only making $10 an hour. After babysitters and gas-- Sidney is 25 minutes from his house-- Damien says his pay was basically a wash. He kept asking for a raise, but wasn't getting one.
而且达米恩每小时只赚10美元。付完保姆费和汽油钱——悉尼离他家有25分钟路程——达米恩说他的工资基本是白费。他一直要求加薪，但没有得到。
And that's when an Instagram friend sent Damien some of the YouTube videos about WakeUpNow. Just like us, he says he'd never seen anything like them before. Unlike us, though, his reaction was--
就在那时，一位Instagram朋友给达米恩发了一些关于“唤醒现在”的YouTube视频。就像我们一样，他说他以前从没见过这样的视频。然而，与我们不同的是，他的反应是——
The video she sent me was so inspiring. I went from being the lowest-paid person in my family to, now, the highest residual income-earner in my family.
她发给我的视频太鼓舞人心了。我从家里收入最低的人变成了现在家里最高的残余收入获得者。
We asked Damien what about the video spoke to him. And what it came down to was the positivity. It was a bunch of young people and, in particular, young black people succeeding as entrepreneurs. They were working for themselves, in total control of their own destiny.
我们问达米恩关于视频的什么打动了他。归结起来就是积极性。这是一群年轻人，特别是年轻的黑人，作为企业家成功了。他们为自己工作，完全掌控自己的命运。
What are you doing in your job?
你在工作中做什么？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑]
To me, it was nostalgic. It took me back to that place, when I was a kid. You dream about where you want to be in your life. And it was like, that's right. That's right. That's what I wanted my life to be. That's right. I'm going after it. Thank you for reminding me. This is my calling right here.
对我来说，这很怀旧。它把我带回了小时候的那个地方。你梦想着你生活中想要到达的地方。就像是，没错。没错。那就是我想要的生活。没错。我正在追求它。谢谢你的提醒。这就是我的使命。
Damien began reading WakeUpNow's literature obsessively. He went on a vacation with his family. And he says, the whole time, he couldn't tear himself away. He compares it to reading scripture. The company's Quick Start Guide includes a whole section called "Your Thoughts can Change the Future." Damien loved that. It talks about feeding yourself positive ideas and filtering out the negative, not hanging around negative people.
达米恩开始痴迷地阅读“唤醒现在”的文献。他带着家人去度假。他说，整段时间，他都无法把自己从这上面拉开。他把它比作阅读经文。公司的“快速入门指南”包含了一个整章，叫“你的思想可以改变未来”。达米恩喜欢那个。它谈论给自己喂养积极的想法，过滤掉消极的想法，不和消极的人在一起。
After that, every dirty joke his co-workers made felt like it was poisoning his mind. Then, after weeks of asking for a raise, his boss told him he wouldn't be getting one. Not long after, Damien quit Restaurant Sidney and devoted himself to WakeUpNow.
在那之后，他的同事讲的每一个脏笑话都让他觉得是在毒害他的思想。然后，在要求加薪数周后，他的老板告诉他他不会得到加薪。没过多久，达米恩辞去了Restaurant Sidney的工作，全身心投入到“唤醒现在”中。
When we visited Damien, he'd been doing WakeUpNow for four months. Here's what a typical work day looks like for him. He wakes up and helps get his two boys off to school. And once they're off, he usually dials into a 10:00 AM motivational group call. But most of the day, he watches his baby daughter.
当我们拜访达米恩时，他做“唤醒现在”已经四个月了。这是他典型的工作日。他醒来并帮助他的两个孩子去学校。一旦他们走了，他通常会拨打上午10点的励志小组电话。但大部分时间，他照顾他的女婴。
While she's napping, he spends a few hours poking around on the computer, watching YouTube videos about how to present WakeUpNow to people and, then, just kind of being on Facebook. If he starts to feel down, he'll watch an uplifting video. Early on, he tried calling every contact in his phone to tell them about WakeUpNow. That yielded exactly one WakeUpNow recruit.
当她午睡时，他花几个小时在电脑上摸索，观看关于如何向人们展示“唤醒现在”的YouTube视频，然后，只是在Facebook上。如果他开始感到情绪低落，他会观看令人振奋的视频。早些时候，他试图给手机里的每个联系人打电话告诉他们关于“唤醒现在”的事。这产生了正好一个“唤醒现在”的新成员。
My mom.
我的妈妈。
His mom. After four months, she's still the only recruit he has, which means he's not making any income. And in fact, he's paying $100 a month to be part of WakeUpNow.
他的妈妈。四个月后，她仍然是他拥有的唯一成员，这意味着他没有任何收入。事实上，他每月支付100美元作为“唤醒现在”的一部分。
What are you going to do if another four months go by and you still haven't gotten anyone and aren't making any money? And you're spending money to be in it?
如果你再过四个月还是没招募到任何人，也没赚到钱怎么办？而你还在花钱加入它？
Um-- that's a hard question. Because I honestly know that it's going to work.
嗯——那是个很难的问题。因为我诚实地知道它会成功。
We spent a lot of time debating with Damien about this. It was nearly impossible to get him to even entertain the hypothetical of WakeUpNow not working.
我们花了很多时间与达米恩辩论这个问题。几乎不可能让他甚至考虑“唤醒现在”不成功这种假设。
If the year goes by and you haven't made any money with WakeUpNow or network marketing, would you be disappointed?
如果一年过去了，你还没赚到钱，无论通过“唤醒现在”还是网络营销，你会失望吗？
No, I would just keep going.
不，我会继续做下去。
Think about that. A year has gone by with no success. You wouldn't feel any kind of way about that?
想一想。一年过去了，没有任何成功。你对此不会有什么感觉吗？
A year gone by-- and network marketing is successful. Think about doctors and lawyers. They go to school for four years, eight years, before they actually reach the time when they can get paid for what they've been training for.
一年过去了——网络营销是成功的。想想医生和律师。他们上学四年、八年，直到他们真正到达可以为他们训练的东西获得报酬的时候。
Damien knows the stats, that just 1% of WakeUpNow members make a living. He actually pointed the numbers out to us on his own. But it's almost as if those dismal statistics made Damien even more optimistic about his prospects.
达米恩知道统计数据，只有1%的“唤醒现在”成员以此为生。他实际上自己向我们指出了这些数字。但几乎就好像那些惨淡的统计数据让达米恩对自己的前景更加乐观。
I have the persistence to become in the 1%, in the less than 1%. Because it says, the results are not typical. Well, I say, I'm not typical. And the thing about it is, more people could be successful. But more people don't have desire. They're not going to put in the work. And if you tell yourself it's too hard, it's going to be too hard.
我有毅力成为那1%中的一员，不到1%。因为它说，结果不是典型的。嗯，我说，我不典型。关于这一点，更多的人本来可以成功的。但更多人没有欲望。他们不会投入工作。如果你告诉自己这太难了，它就会太难。
But what if it's not the fact that you're telling yourself that something is really hard, but that it just is really hard? Like, that is the reality, the chances of making money are low. And so, when someone's telling themself that it's hard, they're right.
但如果事实不是你告诉自己某事很难，而它确实很难呢？就像，那是现实，赚钱的机会很低。所以，当有人告诉自己这很难时，他们是对的。
It's only hard if you believe it's hard.
只有当你相信它很难时，它才难。
We thought that one person who might be silently freaking out about this was Damien's wife, Candice. Candace has a full-time job managing a store at the nearby outlet mall and is now the sole breadwinner in their family of five. They have two kids, a baby and an eight-year-old, and just became the legal guardians of a third child, a 12-year-old who neither is related to, the son of one of Damien's ex-girlfriends.
我们以为可能默默对这一点感到恐慌的一个人是达米恩的妻子坎迪斯（Candice）。坎迪斯在附近的奥特莱斯购物中心管理一家店，拥有全职工作，现在是他们五口之家的唯一养家糊口的人。他们有两个孩子，一个婴儿和一个八岁孩子，刚成为第三个孩子的合法监护人，一个12岁的孩子，两人都没有血缘关系，是达米恩前女友之一的儿子。
So we took Candice aside, out of Damian's earshot, to ask how she was dealing with the pressure of providing for three kids while Damien didn't have a job and wasn't bringing in any money with WakeUpNow.
所以我们把坎迪斯带到一边，在达米恩听不到的地方，问她如何在达米恩没有工作且没有通过“唤醒现在”赚到钱的情况下，应对抚养三个孩子的压力。
I'm not as stressed out. I have a lot more help around the house. So my days off, I actually can enjoy instead of having mounds of laundry to do. [LAUGHS] So like, it's really helped us as a family unit.
我没有那么大的压力。我在家里得到了很多帮助。所以我的休息日，我实际上可以享受，而不是有成堆的衣服要洗。[笑] 所以这确实帮助了我们作为一个家庭单位。
This is not the answer we were expecting. But Candice likes her job. And she says that her income is enough to support the family without Damien earning money. She says they're not in financial trouble at all. When Damien had restaurant gigs where he worked long erratic hours, she and the kids would sometimes go days without seeing him. Now that Damien has left the restaurant industry for WakeUpNow, Candice says her kids get to be raised by their father.
这不是我们期待的答案。但坎迪斯喜欢她的工作。她说她的收入足以支撑这个家庭，无需达米恩赚钱。她说他们根本没有陷入财务困境。当达米恩在餐馆打工时，工作时间很长且不稳定，她和孩子们有时会几天看不到他。现在达米恩为了“唤醒现在”离开了餐馆业，坎迪斯说她的孩子们可以由他们的父亲抚养。
And it's great. Because, with us adding on another child, getting that child in a routine and working on his homework-- because he is behind, so he needs a lot more help and attention with schoolwork and stuff. It's beneficial right now with the dynamics of our family.
这太棒了。因为，随着我们增加另一个孩子，让那个孩子进入常规并做家庭作业——因为他落后了，所以他在学校作业等方面需要更多的帮助和关注。这对我们家庭的动态有益。
And Damien's been able to do that with him?
达米恩能和他一起做那些吗？
Absolutely. He cooks. He does homework. He cleans. So I'm very thankful for that.
绝对。他做饭。他辅导作业。他清洁。所以我非常感激。
Yo! Hi.
嘿！嗨。
Hi.
嗨。
It's 3:30 in the afternoon on a Thursday. And Damien's greeting his boys, Damian Jr. and Leonte, as they get off the school bus. He asked them about their day, explains who these weird radio reporters are in their apartment. And then, they get to homework.
这是周四下午3:30。达米恩正在迎接他的孩子们，小达米恩和莱昂特，因为他们下校车了。他问他们一天过得怎么样，解释这些奇怪的广播记者在他们的公寓里是谁。然后，他们开始做作业。
You have to work on your project.
你必须处理你的项目。
Oh right.
哦，对。
Yeah, right.
是的，没错。
And I got to read.
而且我得读书。
By the way, it's due tomorrow.
顺便说一下，明天截止。
Leonte has to present a biography of Bruce Lee.
莱昂特必须介绍李小龙的传记。
I thought he was Chinese.
我以为他是中国人。
I thought so too, Pooch. Maybe I don't know what's going on. Let's find out.
我也这么以为，Pooch。也许我不知道发生了什么。我们去查查。
He's Chinese and half-German.
他是中国人和德国混血。
Oh, Chinese and half-German. Oh, now, you said American and German first.
哦，中国人和德国混血。哦，现在，你先说了美国和德国。
Oh.
哦。
Yeah, that's a big difference. OK, so just remember that tomorrow.
是的，那有很大的不同。好的，所以明天记得这一点。
Both Damien and Candice say without hesitation that if Damien never makes a dime from WakeUpNow, it still will have been the best move he could have made for their family.
达米恩和坎迪斯都毫不犹豫地说，如果达米恩永远没有从“唤醒现在”赚到一分钱，这仍然会是他能为家庭做出的最好举动。
Bianca Giaever and Brian Reed. A few weeks after the visit, Damien-- he decided to put WakeUpNow on pause. He is no longer a member. He says he's not paying money every month. He wanted to make some money for the holidays, went back to work at TGI Fridays where he's now a waiter, which says he likes a lot more than working in the kitchen.
比安卡·贾维尔和布莱恩·里德。在拜访几周后，达米恩——他决定暂停“唤醒现在”。他不再是成员了。他说他没有每月付钱。他想为节日赚些钱，回到了TGI Fridays工作，现在是一名服务员，他说这比在厨房工作让他喜欢得多。
Coming up, a rich guy tries to wake up other rich guys about the issue of how rich certain rich guys are getting. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个有钱人试图唤醒其他有钱人，关于某些有钱人变得多有钱的问题。一分钟后，当我们的节目在芝加哥公共广播电台继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Today, with people making resolutions for how this new year will be different from the previous one, our show is "Wake Up Now." I hope you notice how classy we're keeping it here on the show by not inserting alarm clock sounds every time I say those words. Wake Up Now-- stories of people trying to wake themselves up or wake up others.
这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。当然，我们每周在节目中选择一个主题。今天，随着人们为新的一年将如何与过去不同做出决定，我们的节目是“唤醒现在”。我希望你注意到我们在节目中保持得多么高级，而不是每次我说这些词时都插入闹钟声。“唤醒现在”——关于人们试图唤醒自己或唤醒他人的故事。
We've arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2, Board Games. So there's this thing that comes up in the news pretty regularly, CEO pay. When it comes up, rarely is it good for the CEOs. Usually, the point is that CEOs are overpaid, something needs to be done. If you figure that most people work 40 or 50 years in their work lives, it would take a typical worker four or five lifetimes to earn what the CEOs of large companies earn in a single year.
我们来到了我们节目的第二幕，第二幕，棋盘游戏。所以新闻中经常出现一件事，首席执行官薪酬。当它出现时，这对首席执行官来说很少是好事。通常重点是首席执行官报酬过高，需要做点什么。如果你算上大多数人在工作生活中工作40或50年，普通工人需要四或五辈子才能赚到大公司首席执行官一年赚的钱。
So you hear statistics like that in these stories. But what you almost never hear is anybody actually trying to cut the pay of a CEO. Well, David Kestenbaum and Jacob Goldstein of NPR'S "Planet Money" found a guy who tried to wake people up to the fact of the CEO of one small company seemed to be making way too much money.
所以你在这些故事中听到了这样的统计数据。但你几乎从没听说有人试图削减首席执行官的薪水。嗯，NPR《货币星球》（Planet Money）的戴维·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）和雅各布·戈德斯坦（Jacob Goldstein）发现了一个试图唤醒人们的事实的人，即一家小公司的首席执行官似乎赚得太多了。
It takes an unusual person to wage a war against a CEO and his pay. The odds of success are just so low. And Tim Stabosz was definitely an outsider.
需要一个不寻常的人才能对首席执行官及其薪酬发动战争。成功的几率太低了。而蒂姆·斯塔博斯（Tim Stabosz）绝对是个局外人。
He lived in a small town, Laporte, Indiana, in a small house. We went to visit. In the dining room, there's a broken Dungeons and Dragons pinball machine. Tim tried to fix it.
他住在印第安纳州拉波特的一个小镇，一个小房子里。我们去拜访了。在餐厅里，有一台坏掉的龙与地下城弹球机。蒂姆试图修复它。
Here it is. Yeah, it's sad. I made a boo-boo when I fried out the display. It was just a disaster.
就是这个。是的，这很悲哀。当我烧毁显示器时我犯了个错误。这真是一场灾难。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑]
When Tim got out of college, he got a government job and tried his hand at the stock market on the side. He used a computer to pick out stocks he thought were undervalued. He still has that computer. And just so you have the right image in your head, this is the kind of computer you'd find sitting out on the sidewalk. It's got a floppy disk drive. And when you turn it on, it just goes beep.
蒂姆大学毕业时，他得到了一份政府工作，并顺便在股票市场上试了试身手。他用一台电脑挑选他认为被低估的股票。他仍然有那台电脑。为了让你脑海中有正确的形象，这就是那种你会发现坐在人行道上的电脑。它有一个软盘驱动器。当你打开它时，它只会发出哔哔声。
[PRINTING NOISE]
[打印声]
That's the dot matrix printer.
那是点阵打印机。
Over the years, Tim did well in the stock market, really well, well enough that he was never going to have to work a regular job again.
多年来，蒂姆在股票市场上做得很好，真的很好，好到他再也不用做普通工作了。
Sometime in the mid '90s, Tim came across this one company. He'd end up investing hundreds of thousands of dollars in its stock. It was a small company based on Long Island called P&F Industries. It made pneumatic tools. You can actually buy them at Home Depot.
九十年代中期某时，蒂姆偶然发现了这家公司。他最终在股票上投资了数十万美元。这是一个总部位于长岛的小公司，叫P&F工业（P&F Industries）。它制造气动工具。你实际上可以在家得宝（Home Depot）买到它们。
Have you ever used one of the tools?
你用过其中的工具吗？
I don't believe so, no.
我不相信有，没有。
Tim just like the company's numbers. It was a small company where you could understand everything about it. P&F seemed like a good deal. But over the years, something began to gnaw at him, the salary of the CEO, Richard Horowitz.
蒂姆只是喜欢这家公司的数字。这是一家小公司，你可以了解关于它的一切。P&F看起来是个好交易。但多年来，有些事情开始困扰他，首席执行官理查德·霍洛维茨（Richard Horowitz）的薪水。
Roughly $1 and 1/2 million a year, total compensation.
每年大约150万美元，总薪酬。
Is that a lot?
那很多吗？
$1 and 1/2 million is outrageous and outlandish.
150万是离谱和荒唐的。
Tim looked around at similar companies, some in the same industry, some in the same geographic area. And he couldn't find any where the CEO was paid even half of what Horowitz made. Now, if you just own a few shares of a company's stock and you think the CEO is overpaid, there isn't much you can do. But if you own more, well, that's different. And by the fall of 2009, Tim owned 180,000 shares.
蒂姆环顾类似的公司，一些在同一个行业，一些在同一个地理区域。他找不到任何一家公司首席执行官的薪水是霍洛维茨的一半。现在，如果你只拥有公司的一点股票，而你认为首席执行官报酬过高，你做不了什么。但如果你拥有更多，好吧，那就不同了。到2009年秋天，蒂姆拥有18万股股份。
I came to own 5%.
我拥有了5%。
5% of the whole company?
整个公司的5%？
5% of the entire company.
整个公司的5%。
His stake was worth more than half a million dollars. And it turned out, Tim had an ally in this fight, a guy with a little more experience, a guy who ran a hedge fund.
他的股份价值超过50万美元。事实证明，蒂姆在这场战斗中有一个盟友，一个有更多经验的人，一个经营对冲基金的人。
I'm Andrew Shapiro. I'm president and portfolio manager of Lawndale Capital Management.
我是安德鲁·夏皮罗（Andrew Shapiro）。我是Lawndale Capital Management的总裁和投资组合经理。
Andrew also owned a big chunk of the company, about 8%. He and Tim didn't work together directly. They had very different styles. Andrew was a by-the-book investor, fond of semi-obscure military allusions.
安德鲁也拥有该公司的一大块股份，大约8%。他和蒂姆没有直接合作。他们有非常不同的风格。安德鲁是一位循规蹈矩的投资者，喜欢半晦涩的军事典故。
With what we do, we deploy what I call the Powell Doctrine of investments. And I try to take on targets where I can mount overwhelming force.
通过我们的工作，我们部署了我称之为投资的“鲍威尔主义”（Powell Doctrine）。我尝试承担目标，在那里我可以施加压倒性的力量。
For years, Andrew had been arguing that the CEO was grossly overpaid. Over one 10-year period, he says, Richard Horowitz took home $13.5 million dollars. That's more than twice what the entire company made in profits over that time.
多年来，安德鲁一直在争论首席执行官的报酬严重过高。他说，在一段10年期间，理查德·霍洛维茨带回家1350万美元。这超过了整个公司在那段时间所赚利润的两倍。
Sometimes, when people complain about CEO pay, they talk about it as if the money's coming out of the pockets of ordinary workers. That is not how Tim and Andrew see it. Every dollar the CEO gets is $1 less profit, $1 less for Tim and Andrew and all the other stockholders.
有时，当人们抱怨首席执行官薪酬时，他们谈论它好像钱是从普通工人的口袋里掏出来的一样。那不是蒂姆和安德鲁看待它的方式。首席执行官得到的每一美元都是利润少了一美元，对蒂姆、安德鲁和所有其他股东来说少了一美元。
The overpaid CEO's taking money out of the shareowner's pocket.
报酬过高的首席执行官正从股东的口袋里拿钱。
You're not in it because, hey, wouldn't it feel great if CEOs weren't paid so much more than everyone else?
你不是为了，嘿，如果首席执行官的薪水没有比其他人高那么多，那感觉不是很好吗？
I am doing this to make a return on our capital.
我做这件事是为了从我们的资本中获得回报。
This is why, if you think CEOs are overpaid rich guys, your best hope for changing things may be other rich guys, rich guys with enough money to buy up a bunch of stock and take on the company to try and cut the CEO's pay, in hopes of becoming even richer themselves.
这就是为什么，如果你认为首席执行官是报酬过高的有钱人，你改变现状的最好希望可能是其他有钱人，那些有足够钱购买一堆股票并承担公司试图削减首席执行官薪水、希望让自己变得更富有的有钱人。
We, of course, wanted to know what the CEO Richard Horowitz had to say about this. We tried to get him. We had a bunch of talks with the company's lawyer. In the end, Horowitz declined to be interviewed. But because this is a public company, there are plenty of recordings of him. Public companies have what are called "quarterly earnings calls" for investors, really anyone who wants to listen.
我们当然想知道首席执行官理查德·霍洛维茨对此有什么看法。我们试图联系他。我们和公司的律师进行了多次谈话。最后，霍洛维茨拒绝接受采访。但因为这是一间上市公司，有很多关于他的录音。上市公司有所谓的针对投资者的“季度收益电话”，实际上任何想听的人都可以听。
Good day, everyone. Thank you for holding. Today's conference will begin with a presentation and, then, a  question and--
大家日安。感谢您的等待。今天的会议将以演示开始，然后是提问和——
The operator starts the call. And then, here is the man himself, Richard Horowitz.
运营商开始电话会议。然后，这就是那个人本人，理查德·霍洛维茨。
Firstly, I'm pleased to report that the company's revenue from continuing operations was $14,164,000.
首先，我很高兴地报告，公司来自持续运营的收入为1416.4万美元。
I've listened to a lot of earnings calls like this over the years. Usually, they are incredibly dull. Analysts from big banks asking super specific things about the company's balance sheet. But remember, P&F is a small company.
多年来我听过很多这样的收益电话。通常，它们极其沉闷。来自大银行的分析师询问关于公司资产负债表的超级具体的事情。但请记住，P&F是一家小公司。
And on some of these calls, there are only two people phoning in with questions, two people who feel the CEO is grossly overpaid, Andrew and Tim. They get to ask the CEO whatever they want. Here's one exchange.
在其中一些电话中，只有两个人打电话进来提问，两个认为首席执行官报酬严重过高的人，安德鲁和蒂姆。他们可以问首席执行官他们想要的任何东西。这里有一个交流。
Thank you. Our next question is from Timothy Stabosz. Your line is--
谢谢。我们的下一个问题来自蒂莫西·斯塔博斯。您的线路是——
Tim is asking about this key thing that's used to determine a CEO's salary. It's called a compensation study. It looks at what CEOs at comparable companies are earning. P&F Industries had hired an external firm to do one of these reports. And Tim wanted details.
蒂姆问关于确定首席执行官薪水所使用的这个关键点。它叫薪酬研究。它着眼于可比公司的首席执行官赚多少钱。P&F工业雇佣了一家外部公司来做其中一份报告。而蒂姆想要细节。
--a little shocked. That's  the best I can tell you.
——有点震惊。这是我能告诉你的最好的。
So we're still waiting on a report from that outside firm, right?
所以我们还在等那家外部公司的报告，对吧？
I can't tell you. I don't know what the comp committee-- I mean, I don't-- I can't answer that question. I don't have the knowledge to answer that question.
我不能告诉你。我不知道薪酬委员会做了什么——我的意思是，我——我不能回答那个问题。我没有知识来回答那个问题。
OK, um--
好的，嗯——
I'm not being evasive. I just don't know the answer, Tim. I'm sorry.
我不是在回避。我只是不知道答案，蒂姆。对不起。
OK. Well, you know that there's a firm that's-- we've certainly announced that there's a firm that's doing an analysis, right?
好的。嗯，你知道有家公司——我们当然宣布了有一家公司在做分析，对吧？
I can't-- I don't know.
我不能——我不知道。
Does anyone in that room know?
那个房间里有人知道吗？
It's not the purview of--
这不是……的职权范围——
Does the attorney for the company know?
公司的律师知道吗？
Tim, I can't comment any further. And this is a Q2 conference call.
蒂姆，我不能再评论了。这是一个第二季度电话会议。
Q2 means second quarter.
Q2代表第二季度。
We're talking about the results of Q2.
我们正在讨论第二季度的结果。
Well--
嗯——
So please, please, please, Tim, and Andrew and anybody else, please, let's keep the comments to the Q2 numbers. Thank you.
所以请，请，请，蒂姆，安德鲁和任何其他人，请，把评论保留给第二季度的数字。谢谢。
Well, that's fine. But executive salaries are relevant to the future profitability and whatnot.
嗯，这很好。但高管薪水与未来的盈利能力等相关。
I can't comment any further, Tim. Any other questions about the Q2?
我不能再评论了，蒂姆。还有关于第二季度的其他问题吗？
Well, it would have been helpful if you would have simply said, we're not going to talk about executive compensation, period. Because that's what you're essentially saying, right?
嗯，如果你简单地说，我们不会谈论高管薪酬，句号，那会很有帮助。因为那基本上就是你所说的，对吧？
Any other questions about Q2, Tim?
还有关于第二季度的其他问题吗，蒂姆？
I'll get back in queue. I'm frustrated right now, Richard.
我会回到队列里。我现在很沮丧，理查德。
OK, you'll handle it.
好的，你会处理好的。
Thank you. Our next question is from Andrew Shapiro. Your line is open.
谢谢。我们的下一个问题来自安德鲁·夏皮罗。您的线路已打开。
There are a lot of calls like this.
有很多像这样的电话。
A CEO's salary is set by a company's board of directors. And Shapiro suspected Richard Horowitz had packed the board with his cronies, people who paid him more than he deserved. So Andrew hired a private detective and did some digging himself. He discovered that, in fact, several board members played golf at the same country club as the CEO.
首席执行官的薪水由公司的董事会设定。夏皮罗怀疑理查德·霍洛维茨用他的亲信填满了董事会，那些付给他比他应得更多的钱的人。所以安德鲁雇了一名私家侦探并自己进行了挖掘。他发现，事实上，几名董事会成员与首席执行官在同一个乡村俱乐部打高尔夫球。
The Glen Oaks Country Club of Westbury, New York. Glen Oaks Country Club of Old Westbury, New York.
纽约州韦斯特伯里的格伦奥克斯乡村俱乐部（Glen Oaks Country Club of Westbury, New York）。纽约州旧韦斯特伯里的格伦奥克斯乡村俱乐部。
Nothing illegal or maybe even surprising about these guys blowing into the same country club. But still, what would General Colin Powell do? He'd get them off the board. Andrew suggested several potential new board members. And Tim, Tim nominated himself.
关于这些人吹嘘同一个乡村俱乐部并没有什么违法，甚至也许并不令人惊讶。但仍然，科林·鲍威尔（Colin Powell）将军会做什么？他会把他们踢出董事会。安德鲁建议了几位潜在的新董事会成员。而蒂姆，蒂姆提名了他自己。
Getting new people on a board is tough. There is a vote. But in most cases, the existing board members get to decide who's on the ballot. It's as if members of Congress were the ones who decided who got to run for Congress.
让新的人进入董事会很难。有一个投票。但在大多数情况下，现任董事会成员可以决定谁在选票上。这就好比国会议员决定谁可以竞选国会议员。
So Tim and Andrew went to the company's annual meeting to try to convince the board to put their candidates on the ballot. It was the first time Andrew Shapiro and Richard Horowitz, the CEO, had met in person.
所以蒂姆和安德鲁参加了公司的年度会议，试图说服董事会把他们的候选人放在选票上。这是安德鲁·夏皮罗和理查德·霍洛维茨第一次亲自见面。
It actually was quite crowded. Every seat at the table was full. And there was the paid-for advisers standing around the periphery of the table, in the room, but along the wall.
它实际上相当拥挤。桌子上的每个座位都满了。在桌子的外围，房间里，但在墙边，有付费的顾问站着。
Where was the CEO?
首席执行官在哪里？
Oh, he's sitting directly across the table from me.
噢，他正坐在我对面。
Oh, it must be awkward. What's it like?
噢，那一定很尴尬。那是什么感觉？
Oh, it's not awkward or not. I go into these rooms with the distinct view that I am an owner of this business and you members of the board of directors are my agents. And you work for me. You don't work for Mr. Horowitz. You don't work for management. Management works for you, the board. And the board, you work for me and all of the other shareholders.
噢，没什么尴尬不尴尬的。我走进这些房间，有明确的观点，我是这项业务的所有者，而你们董事会成员是我的代理人。你们为我工作。你们不为霍洛维茨先生工作。你们不为管理层工作。管理层为您（董事会）工作。而董事会，你们为我和所有其他股东工作。
The board did not seem immediately swayed by this argument. And it's easy to imagine how this whole thing might feel on the other side if you're, say, Richard Horowitz, the CEO; if you've got two guys who have never even worked in the tool business telling you how they think the business that your father built up should be run and how much you should be paid and who should be on your board.
董事会似乎并没有立即被这个论点所左右。很容易想象如果如果你是理查德·霍洛维茨，首席执行官，如果你有两个从未在工具行业工作过的人告诉你他们认为你父亲建立的业务应该如何经营，你应该拿多少报酬，谁应该在你的董事会里，这一切在另一方会是什么感觉。
For Tim Stabosz, what had started out as a rational investment, something just based on numbers, had become emotional, had become something hard to let go of. At some point in this whole fight, Tim's letters to the company took on a different tone. He got rid of the lawyer who'd been vetting them.
对于蒂姆·斯塔博斯来说，开始作为一个理性的投资，仅仅基于数字的东西，已经变得情绪化了，已经变得难以放手。在这个战斗的某个时刻，蒂姆给公司的信件带上了不同的语调。他解雇了一直审查它们的律师。
Some of the letters start to have words in all caps. Some start to feel weirdly intimate. One is addressed just to Richard and uses phrases like, "I was at the end of my rope," and, "goodness knows, I tried a different course."
有些信件开始有全部大写的单词。有些开始感到奇怪地亲密。一封只写给理查德，使用诸如“我到了我的绳子尽头”和“上帝知道，我尝试了不同的课程”之类的短语。
And then, in the summer of 2010, more than a decade after Tim first bought stock in P&F Industries, something finally went his way. There was a change on the board. The two guys who played golf at the same country club as the CEO stepped down from the committee that set the CEO's pay.
然后，在2010年夏天，在蒂姆第一次买P&F工业股票十多年后，事情终于朝着他的方向发展了。董事会发生了变化。那两个与首席执行官在同一个乡村俱乐部打高尔夫球的人从设定首席执行官薪酬的委员会中卸任了。
Also, one of the people Andrew had recommended for the board got put on the ballot and elected.
此外，安德鲁推荐进入董事会的人之一被列入选票并当选了。
And a year and a half later-- if you haven't noticed, this is an incredibly long process-- it finally happened, the thing that almost never happens. The board of P&F did what Andrew and Tim wanted. They cut Richard Horowitz's base salary by a lot, from $975,000 to $650,000, a cut of over $300,000.
一年半后——如果你没注意到，这是一个极其漫长的过程——它终于发生了，几乎从未发生过的事情。P&F董事会做了安德鲁和蒂姆想做的事。他们大幅削减了理查德·霍洛维茨的基本薪水，从97.5万美元降至65万美元，削减了超过30万美元。
It actually made the news, at least a little corner of the news, an article in a publication called "Institutional Investor." An expert in that article said it was the first time he'd ever seen shareholders get a board to cut the pay of a sitting CEO.
它实际上成了新闻，至少是新闻的一角，一份名为《机构投资者》（Institutional Investor）的刊物上的一篇文章。那篇文章中的一位专家说，这是他见过的第一次股东让董事会削减在任首席执行官的薪水。
Tim Stabosz, of course, was elated about the pay cut.
蒂姆·斯塔博斯当然对减薪感到欣喜若狂。
Well, it felt fantastic. It felt great. It felt like I had served to effect this change, that I was an agent of change.
嗯，这感觉很棒。感觉很好。感觉我为促成这种改变提供了服务，我是变革的代理人。
That feeling did not last. It turns out, that new contract also made it easier for Richard Horowitz to get a bigger bonus. And in 2012, even though Horowitz's base pay had been cut, he actually ended up making more money than he had the previous year.
那种感觉并没有持续。事实证明，那份新合同也让理查德·霍洛维茨更容易获得更大的奖金。在2012年，尽管霍洛维茨的基本薪水被削减了，他实际上最终比前一年赚了更多的钱。
And then, earlier this year, Richard Horowitz got a raise. The board boosted his base pay by $50,000.
然后，今年早些时候，理查德·霍洛维茨加薪了。董事会将他的基本工资提高了5万美元。
And they also raised the bonus percentages, so he would be able to earn even more on the bonus.
他们还提高了奖金百分比，这样他就能在奖金上赚得更多。
The company only let us talk to one person on its side of things. But it was someone we definitely wanted to hear from, the board member that Andrew Shapiro had recommended. We met him one afternoon at a business club at the top of a tall building in Philadelphia. His name is Howard Brownstein. And he told us he thinks Richard Horowitz's pay is reasonable.
公司只让我们和他们一边的一人交谈。但这绝对是我们想听的人，安德鲁·夏皮罗推荐的那位董事会成员。我们在费城一栋高楼顶部的商业俱乐部见到了他。他叫霍华德·布朗斯坦（Howard Brownstein）。他告诉我们他认为理查德·霍洛维茨的薪酬是合理的。
Yeah, I would say to you that, based on the work that the comp committee did, as they reported it to us and as we listened to it, that the compensation is within the realm of reasonableness for our company and how it's doing and the money we make for the shareholders.
是的，我会告诉你，根据薪酬委员会所做的工作，正如他们向我们报告的那样，正如我们所听到的那样，薪酬在我们公司及其实际表现以及我们为股东赚的钱的合理范围内。
We asked Brownstein about that compensation study that Tim asked about on the conference call, the study that compares Richard Horowitz's pay to the CEOs of other companies. And we read Brownstein this letter Tim wrote, asking the board to release details from the report. "Asked" is probably the wrong word. Tim writes, I demand, in all caps. And then, at the end, also in caps, I have waited long enough. I am done waiting.
我们问布朗斯坦关于蒂姆在电话会议上问的薪酬研究，那个比较理查德·霍洛维茨薪水与其他公司首席执行官薪水的研究。我们读给布朗斯坦蒂姆写的那封要求董事会发布报告细节的信。“要求”大概是错误的词。蒂姆写道，我要求（Demand），全部大写。然后，最后，也用大写，我已经等得够久了。我不想再等了。
Well, Mr. Stabosz obviously hasn't been able to find the Caps Lock key on his typewriter. Look, generally in my world, when somebody demands something, it's because they have a legal right to it. He may say he demands it, but the fact is, he doesn't have a right to it. So what he really meant when he said, I demand it, is I really, really want it. I get it. It's OK. You can't have it. Next.
嗯，斯塔博斯先生显然还没能在他的打字机上找到大写锁定键。看，通常在我的世界里，当某人要求某事时，是因为他们拥有法律权利。他说他要求它，但事实是，他没有权利拥有它。所以当他说“我要求它”时，他真正意思是，我真的、真的非常想要它。我懂。没关系。你不能拥有它。下一个。
He's one of the owners of the company, right?
他是公司的所有者之一，对吧？
Sure he is. But the owners of the company only have the rights that they have, the rights the law gives them. It doesn't give them more than that.
当然他是。但公司的所有者只拥有他们拥有的权利，法律赋予他们的权利。它不给他们超出此范围的权利。
Since P&F wouldn't release that study, we asked a company that analyzes CEO compensation to take a look. The company is called Equilar. They do a lot of work for companies who are trying to figure out how much to pay their CEOs.
因为P&F不会发布那份研究，我们要求一家分析首席执行官薪酬的公司看一看。这家公司叫Equilar。他们为试图弄清楚支付多少薪水给首席执行官的公司做了很多工作。
Here is what Equilar found. Among roughly 200 companies of similar size, Richard Horowitz's pay ranked near the very top, in the top 7%, more than twice the average. Equilar also looked at a smaller group of companies that, like P&F, are in what's called the "industrial goods" sector. There were 13 companies in that group. The top paid CEO was Richard Horowitz.
这就是Equilar发现的。在大约200家类似规模的公司中，理查德·霍洛维茨的薪水排在几乎顶端，前7%，平均值的两倍多。Equilar还查看了另一组较小的公司，它们像P&F一样，属于所谓的“工业品”领域。该组中有13家公司。报酬最高的首席执行官是理查德·霍洛维茨。
In other words, according to the study, Richard Horowitz is one of the highest paid or the highest paid CEO for what he does.
换句话说，根据该研究，理查德·霍洛维茨是同类工作中报酬最高或最高的首席执行官。
Tim Stabosz lost. But he had owned shares in P&F for most of his adult life. And when you've been in something that long, it can be hard to know when to walk away.
蒂姆·斯塔博斯输了。但他拥有P&F的股份几乎是他成年后的大部分时间。当你做某件事这么久时，可能很难知道什么时候走开。
What happens next? Are you going to keep at this?
接下来会发生什么？你还要继续这样做吗？
That's a good question. I hadn't thought about that. Um, yeah, yeah. I want the company to know that I'm not going anywhere.
这是个好问题。我还没想过那个。嗯，是的，是的。我想让公司知道我哪儿也不去。
Do you ever think about giving up?
你想过放弃吗？
Um, no.
嗯，不。
Really?
真的吗？
Well, I mean, I'm trying to think about what giving up means.
嗯，我的意思是，我试图思考放弃意味着什么。
I can tell you what giving up looks like. After we talked to Tim this summer, he had a momentary cash crunch. He had to sell all his shares. The company bought them from him. And as part of the deal, Tim promised not to buy any shares of P&F Industries for three years.
我可以告诉你放弃看起来像什么。在今年夏天我们和蒂姆交谈后，他经历了短暂的现金紧缩。他不得不卖掉所有股份。公司从他那里买下了它们。作为交易的一部分，蒂姆承诺三年内不购买任何P&F工业的股票。
It turns out it's really hard to cut a CEO's pay, even if you own 5% of the company. Now, he has even less power to do anything about it. Now, Tim Stabosz is just like everybody else.
事实证明，要削减首席执行官的薪水真的很难，即使你拥有公司的5%。现在，他在处理这件事上拥有的权力更少了。现在，蒂姆·斯塔博斯就像其他人一样。
Jacob Goldstein and David Kestenbaum from the NPR podcast "Planet Money," the very entertaining podcast about economics. Get it for free at npr.org/money or whenever you get your podcasts.
雅各布·戈德斯坦和戴维·克斯滕鲍姆来自NPR播客《货币星球》，关于经济的非常有趣的播客。在npr.org/money或任何你获得播客的地方免费获取它。
[MUSIC - "BIG BOSS MAN" BY KOKO TAYLOR]
[音乐 - “大老板”（Big Boss Man） - 科科·泰勒（Koko Taylor）]
Act 3, Sleep No More. OK, so to end today's program about waking up, let's leave the world of metaphor completely. So we're not talking about waking up to a new way of seeing the world or waking up to the things you need to do to change your life or waking up other people to the issue of overpaid CEOs, or whatever issue. I'm talking about just waking up, just waking up, pure and simple. That shouldn't be hard, right? You do it every day.
第三幕，永不入眠。好吧，所以为了结束今天关于醒来的节目，让我们完全离开隐喻的世界。所以我们不是在谈论醒来迎接看待世界的新方式，或者醒来处理你需要做的改变生活的事情，或者唤醒其他人关注报酬过高的首席执行官问题，无论什么问题。我是在谈论只是醒来，只是醒来，纯粹而简单。那不应该很难，对吧？你每天都这样做。
[ALARM BEEPING]
[闹钟哔哔声]
Springfield, Oregon, Monday morning during finals week, 7:30. Morgan Peach, a grad student hears the alarm that's supposed to wake him up. And he shuts it off. This happens again at 7:35.
俄勒冈州斯普林菲尔德，期末周周一早上，7:30。莫根·皮奇（Morgan Peach），一名研究生听到了本该叫醒他的闹钟。他关掉了它。这在7:35再次发生。
[ALARM BEEPING]
[闹钟哔哔声]
And again at 7:40.
然后在7:40又一次。
[MOANING]
[呻吟声]
[ALARM BEEPING]
[闹钟哔哔声]
Once more at 7:45.
在7:45再来一次。
[ALARM BEEPING]
[闹钟哔哔声]
You get the idea, 8:15, 8:25. Finally, 9 o'clock, his girlfriend, Angela Evancie, who made this recording, steps in.
你明白了，8:15，8:25。最后，9点钟，制作此录音的女朋友安吉拉·埃万西（Angela Evancie）介入了。
[DEEP INHALE] It's time.
[深吸气] 是时候了。
It's time.
是时候了。
Right. He doesn't get up. Besides an exam, he has two research papers to turn in and 55 exams and papers to grade. Angela sees him struggle everyday with waking up. But she thought, this week-- this week-- for once, he would do it when the alarm sounds, because he has so much to do.
对。他没有起来。除了考试，他还有两篇研究论文要交，以及55场考试和论文要打分。安吉拉每天看到他为醒来而挣扎。但她以为，这周——这周——这一次，当闹钟响起时他会起来的，因为他有很多事要做。
Tuesday, it goes off first at 7:30, then seven more times. 7:40, 7:45, 8 o'clock, 8:05, 8:10, 8:15, 8:20. Wednesday, pretty much the same deal. At some point, Angela says to her sleeping boyfriend--
周二，它首先在7:30响起，然后又响了七次。7:40，7:45，8点，8:05，8:10，8:15，8:20。周三，基本情况一样。在某个时候，安吉拉对她睡觉的男朋友说——
You set the alarm for 9 o'clock?
你设闹钟到9点了吗？
Yes, I did.
是的，我设了。
Can you afford to sleep in that late?
你睡得起那么晚吗？
Certainly can. I'm wealthy in time, not in money.
当然可以。我的时间很富有，钱不富有。
People can be surprisingly articulate when they're barely awake sometimes. Wednesday night, Morgan tells Angela that the next morning, Thursday, he actually is going to have to get up. The geography paper's due at noon.
人们有时在几乎醒着的时候可以惊人地表达清楚。周三晚上，莫根告诉安吉拉，第二天早上，周四，他实际上不得不起来。地理论文中午截止。
Yeah, could you set the alarm for 7:30 tomorrow? I'd like to get up at 7:30 and work on my research papers and finish them.
是的，你能把明天闹钟设到7:30吗？我想在7:30起来，研究我的研究论文并完成它们。
So next morning.
所以第二天早上。
(WHISPERING) And now it's 8:00. The alarm went off. And he reset it for 8:30. I really thought he was going to do it this morning.
（低语）现在8点钟了。闹钟响了。他把它重置到8:30。我真的以为他今天早上会做的。
Sometime near 10:00 AM, they finally have this conversation.
大约上午10点某时，他们终于有了这个对话。
It's time to get up.
该起床了。
[YAWN] That's what you always say.
[哈欠] 你总是这么说。
And then, still lying in bed. He explains the whole thing perfectly. It would be impossible to say this better.
然后，仍然躺在床上。他完美地解释了整个事情。不可能说得更好。
(SLEEPILY) It's almost as if the sleeping is that much sweeter when you have to get up or you think you have to get up, and then you don't.
（睡眼惺忪地）当必须起来或你认为你必须起来时，而你没有起来，睡觉就显得更甜了。
[MUSIC - "WAKE UP EVERYBODY" BY JOHN LEGEND AND THE ROODS, FEATURING COMMON & MELANIE FIONA]
[音乐 - “唤醒大家”（Wake Up Everybody） - 约翰·传奇（John Legend）与The Roots，特邀Common和梅兰妮·菲奥娜（Melanie Fiona）]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from JP Dukes.
今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）制作，与肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·傅（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。制作帮助来自JP·杜克斯（JP Dukes）。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Editing help today from Joel Lovell. Research help from Christopher Swetala and Benjamin Anastas. Music help from Damen Graef.
塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责我们的网站。今天的编辑帮助来自乔尔·洛弗尔（Joel Lovell）。研究帮助来自克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）和本杰明·阿纳斯塔斯（Benjamin Anastas）。音乐帮助来自达门·格拉夫（Damen Graef）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, our spin-off program, Serial , serialpodcast.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. This is what he said to the crowd immediately after Peter Sagal dropped by the WBEZ Christmas party for five minutes.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，我们的衍生节目《连环》（Serial），serialpodcast.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。这是他在彼得·萨加尔（Peter Sagal）在WBEZ圣诞派对停留五分钟后立即对人群说的话。
Wow. All right.
哇。好了。